- dots can be found out here on the
mountains of southwestern Germany with
his flock of sheep all year round and
this chef comes here to buy lamb for his
restaurant he likes that it's a local
product this llama says to be sure this
lamb is a typical product of the Swabian
Alps and the Sheep help maintain the
meadows in grassland like Maharaja
Hutton babe the sheep graze on wild
herbs like ground ivy wild sage marjoram
and wild garlic they're Hardy creatures
and constantly on the move which makes
their meat especially tasty you think
InDesign probably we need to make sure
that the products that the farmers and
Shepherds produce here and up on our
menus later the food Yergin out and eat
and his brother run the Hammond hotel in
the town of Moon singen they've been
focusing on regional cooking for a long
time now since well before the slow food
concept caught on here
they sell local products and their menu
features local ingredients
in the winter the menu features lamb
accompanied by lamb's lettuce and alb
lentils a traditional local variety that
was rediscovered not long ago we wished
investigation we want our guests to
taste the regional flavors on their
plates and at night in bed they should
really feel like they're in the Swabian
Alps the new section of the hotel was
built made of local woods which adds to
the warm and comfortable atmosphere
we continue to vomit ah in North
rhine-westphalia the neighborhood near
the suspension railway is home to [ __ ]
mail a writer and cookbook author this
summer he also opened a small eatery
called fine a cost
it's a lovely and relaxed place to come
for breakfast or lunch last inning
my main goal was creating a place where
you can have tasty vegetarian and vegan
meals in the middle of town that's still
fairly rare here and it's the main idea
behind my cafe I just love it I know to
help them feel within loud Nietzel
muffin soup is always on the menu this
one is seasoned with the chutney and a
garnish then there's a selection of
three seasonal vegetable dishes or you
can order a combination plate with a
taste of all three
annyong important evens nutrition
affects your body and your spirit too
that's why food can make you happy
that's what's so fascinating about
Ayurveda
it's a way to use food to gain access to
your inner being direct in Subang and
some in Lebanon Finnegan has four Khmer
cooks in accordance with a Aveda a
traditional Indian philosophy zu schmack
Glueck or the flavor of happiness is the
name of his latest cookbook alongside
seasonal and regional dishes it also
includes the cook state of mind was
active in Ayurveda the cooks energy is
transmitted to the food and to those who
eat it focused cooking classes are
booked out months in advance today the
students are preparing a four-course
meal they brought the most important
ingredient with them positive energy
let's go looking with other people is a
lot of fun
or despise the cooks attitude always
affects the meal this is a nice and
relaxed group tonight it's fun locked
balls and the evenings highlight is
enjoying the meal together we move on
now to the small town of tongue stead
near Hamburg which is home to Rebecca
and Matthias cthugha they also put the
principles of regional cooking into
practice in their restaurant
gute Scotia it's located on the woods
feta organic farm which employs 150
people all the vegetables on their menu
are grown here Leedy yeah when you can
eat what you grow and live that life
that's wonderful this is for a cook it's
the best thing there is
it's hearty regional fare with a modern
twist the restaurant offers a
five-course seasonal menu each day every
course can also be ordered separately
one typical winter dessert is a layered
pastry parfait with pears and a verbena
pesto
one of the main dishes today is braised
beef with carrots as cooks Rebecca and
Mattias put a premium on sustainability
when meat is on the menu everything
that's not on the plate is used to make
a broth mullet Rashad's cockles as a
cook we have a responsibility to use our
skills and use the entire beef carcass
it's irresponsible behavior when a cook
only uses the fillet and says fine the
rest of it isn't my problem they also
appreciate openness and transparency the
feel of the concept by concept also
emphasizes making everything visible our
storage areas for food and wine are
accessible and our guests can watch us
prepare the meals we want to be
accessible to our guests and explain
what we're doing Felix lianca
slow food that's regional sustainable
and delicious for the guests it's the
perfect way to enjoy an evening